what's up buddy hey rich how's things
all is good it's always good man how you
doing
uh i i can't do not interrupt here i
cannot like you you know i love uh i
love macro economic and i want to give
like some some insights for for the guys
you know uh
like long time ago i i i was reading the
economist and i read a code that i will
never
forget it's
it says if the market have a gender it
will be a female
and if the economy have a gender it will
be a male
you have to understand guys that women
spend around 28 trillion dollar per year
on this planet
28 trillion dollar per year that's what
they what they mean by the market the
purchasing market that's that's what it
is it's actually 80
of the buying power so women spend 80 of
the money right now they don't make 80
of the money so
you guys can connect the dots on where
the money comes from and who spends the
money you guys can figure that out i
mean you're smarter yeah they they make
actually they make actually around 14
but they they spend 28 trillion yeah so
uh so you have to invest as as i always
advise for the guys on on my following
on my channel you have to invest in
women's delusion
[Laughter]
that's the best market for the future
there's a um
like okay so i want to stop you there
because yeah um i don't want you to go
somewhere that might cause problems for
my channel but there's but there's
clever guys out there right now that are
structuring businesses that cater to the
delusion of the world today you know the
wokeness the agendas all that sort of
stuff and
um now
you've got to be careful with that like
i'll be honest with you i saw what was
going on with disney and then i piled
some money into disney this is this is
before you know this you know the [ __ ]
that's going on with desantis and
florida and all that i'm like
you know what
they're
you know they're wokifying it everything
i might as well make some money at it
and i'll profit at it but now desantis
is like coming at them and a lot of the
wokeness is like you know coming back to
shoot them in the foot so you have to be
careful with it but yeah there there is
a cottage industry of people that are
monetizing the
agendas that are being crammed down
everybody's throat today i think i think
that we can just leave it at that you
guys can figure that out but yeah we can
talk about that privately on the zooms
i have examples like small examples from
industry which is that the ivf freeze
eggs industry sure which is the the pit
industry the pit the dogs cats like and
their accessories and their knees and
the beauty industry like these three
main example and i had like one of one
of the one of the guys who follow my
channel like he heard the around one
year ago
me talking about this and he sent me a
like a long email telling me that he was
investing like he he got a big shop for
uh for the pit
for the pit and their accessories
he's telling me you're right 90 of my
clients are women and i'm doing so well
let me um let me tell you something
about the pet industry here
in canada because
when i was doing those um
applications for
the hyper growth awards there's
there's either 50 entrepreneurs in the
room or there was 200 and there was this
one girl that i met there who was
running a pet clothing company
and um
she was like in the top i think 15 or
something like that like she had very
very fast growth and super profitable
she was actually um
chinese so she would fly to asia she had
all the contacts there she could speak
you know the language and she was
bringing over this cheap [ __ ] clothing
that
basically post-wall women were
essentially buying and putting on their
dogs
um and it was dog targeted so it was
like you know booties and and like
ribbons and
all this like fufu stuff but
she did very well man so yeah there's a
lot of money to be made in those
industries too
yeah yeah yeah that's like that's why
that's what i want to say thank you
thank you
see you agree bye-bye thank you
again guys if you want the course if
you're watching live it's pinned at the
top of the live chat if you're listening
to the replay i'll make sure it's in the
description and pin in the top comment
of the youtube channel
uh do you think there's an opportunity
to specialize in positive masculinity
and therapy i work in counseling i want
to target young adult males
um
you know that's interesting because
i think you'd probably be better
targeting the simp economy
only fans has proven to be a very very
profitable
business model
can you target positive masculinity and
therapy
yeah
but
see
one of the things i talk about in the
course of the modules is that people
like buying painkillers they don't like
buying vitamins
and
um the simp economy
you know like essentially is a
painkiller for sims they want to
um interact with and engage with
attractive women they want to be with
and only fans scratches that itch
um
if you're if you're selling them a
vitamin like positive masculinity
people don't generally buy that i mean
you do have an audience for that like
there are
i mean i take loads of vitamins i sell a
supplement line you know like these
don't kill pain like these help you grow
muscle burn fat lower your estrogen
boost your testosterone all that stuff
right so
um selling vitamins can be done i'm not
saying that um you shouldn't do it do it
if it's what you feel passionate about
you think you got a good angle but just
understand
when you're selling painkillers aka you
know to the simp economy you probably
build a faster growing business
unfortunately
you